Ever wondered what members of an elite SCP
Foundation Mobile Task Force secretly desire?
Foundation researchers snapped a picture of
a member Mobile Task Force Beta-7 "Maz Hatters"
using SCP-978, The Desire Camera, while they
were standing in casual clothing with a neutral
expression, and this was the result:
"The room is much cleaner."
Nothing much changed in the photo, aside from
the cleanliness of the room.
It seems that the subject's desires were simple,
and extremely achievable - Which makes sense,
given that the Maz Hatters specialize in the
cleanup of toxic waste.
A member of the cleaning staff was promptly
brought in to tidy up the space, and for once,
the desire reflected by SCP-978 was actually
realized.